we're told that adam flew his remote
controlled drone off of a platform the
function f
models the height of the drone above the
ground in meters as a function of time
in seconds after takeoff
so they want us to do is plot the point
on the graph of f that corresponds to
each of the following things so pause
the video and see if you can do that and
obviously you can't draw on your screen
this is from an exercise on khan academy
but you can visually look at it and even
with your finger point to the part of
the graph of f that represents each of
these things
all right so the first thing here is the
height of the platform
so the drone is at the height of the
platform right when it takes off because
it says adam flew his remote control
drone off of a platform
so what is the time that he's taking off
the drone or the drone is taking off
well that's going to be at time t equals
zero right over here and what is the
height of the drone at that moment it is
60 meters so that must be the height of
the platform so that point right over
there tells us the height of the
platform and if they asked us what the
height of the platform is it would be 60
meters
the next one is the drone's maximum
height
so then as time goes on we can see the
drone starts going to a higher and
higher and higher height gets as high as
80 meters and then it starts going down
so it looks like 80 meters at time 10
seconds the drone hits a maximum height
of 80 meters
and then last but not least they say the
time when the drone landed on the ground
now we can assume that the ground is
when the height of the drone is at zero
meters and we can see that that happens
right over here and that happens at time
t equals 30 seconds and so we've just
marked it off and i know some but some
of y'all are thinking wait there's
another time where the drone is where
the drone's height is at zero and that's
right over here that's at negative 10
seconds couldn't we say that that's also
a time when the drone landed on the
ground and this is a important point to
realize because if we're really trying
to model the drones behavior from time t
equals zero if t equals zero is right
when you take off all the way to it
lands then this parabola that we're
showing right over here it actually we
would probably want to restrict its
domain to positive times and so this
negative time region right over here
really doesn't make a lot of sense we
should probably consider the
non-negative values of time when we're
trying to think about these different
things